[Music]
mr. Luke pal yeah the return of you to
the bachelor world you were kind of
supposed to be the bachelor
yeah and that didn't happen this is not
supposed to be happening as much as is
it it was shocking for me to not end up
being you know getting casted as the
bachelor it was also very much you know
quick it came and went really quick and
so I moved on and went back to Nashville
and just kind of picked up where I left
off in life and there were kind of some
rumors about you and dating a lot of
girls and maybe being a bit of a player
I went through a phase where I learned a
lot about how intentional you have to be
about who you talk to who you begin to
date or not date or not trust and and
you know that was post Bachelorette for
me and so I began to hold my cards a lot
closer to my chest and maybe you know
somebody that's wanting some attention
from the tabloids that's not getting it
and I that I didn't end up in a
relationship with them and it becomes a
thing well why did we not see one
paradise why was winter named say yes I
was actually planning on to go on
paradise last season and it I started a
relationship with somebody and it was it
was good but you know time went by and
this came up and I was single and so I
said hey okay okay here we go what about
your winter sports skills marginal at
best I'm just I'm just trying not to
hurt myself trying to pull the hamstring
you